this week we're talking about security
code performance and machine learning
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news google
cloud is already known for great
security but we're excited to take that
even further with Chronicle joining the
Google cloud family
this means more tools such as malware
intelligence services will be available
to use with your cloud infrastructure
and your data enabling you to detect and
mitigate threats faster read more about
the details and prepare to buff up your
security investigating production code
just got easier with stack driver
profiler
now generally available profiler lets
you look at how your code runs and
breaks down where time and resources are
being spent with no noticeable
performance impact there's a great
session from Google cloud next with more
details so check it out and start
improving your production code bigquery
is now integrated with kaggle making it
easier and faster to analyze data and
train models kaggle is where the world's
largest online community of data
scientists come together and it offers
tools like kernels a free host of
Jupiter notebooks environment these two
great tools are even greater when
integrated so start by linking your
account and try out the new tutorials to
query like never before it can take a
lot of time to set up a machine learning
project especially with managing the
complexity and compatibility issues of
an ever-evolving software stack when
you'd rather just spend time refining
your model
deep learning containers are a great
place to start these containers are
prepackaged performance optimized and
compatibility tested so you have a
consistent environment to work in follow
along with the tutorial and use the beta
deep learning containers to get to the
fun stuff if you want to read more about
these announcements or see a full list
check out the link have any thoughts or
ideas leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you